[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you just
tapped into the group chat live in the
bleacher report at presented by fanduel
i'm greg ivory alongside
aaron dolan gabby is on pto
during the conference finals must be
nice huh eric
yeah i would love to take a vacation
during the conference finals sip on a
spicy mark while i watch the game on an
island i mean that
sounds ideal to me
tulum is definitely calling my name but
the hoodies
is also calling you guys his name we got
hoodies to give away we got nba jerseys
to give away
and the first one is going out right
now i'm about to hook somebody up in the
chat with 125
to pick out whatever jersey they want
aaron aaron do you want to introduce
what this is to the people that do not
know
that is the handy dandy ipad
yes aaron yes this right here is the
handy dandy ipad
and this is how you guys when jerseys
win hoodies
i'm in the comments aaron i am in the
comments and i see uh
i see deke geek i see deep geek in the
comments shout out to you d
geek he is uh he's he's somebody that's
always here aaron i'm still in the
comments and i'm giving away a jersey
this time
giving away a jersey i got eddie go big
get me on the go
eddie eddie on the go says ice tray with
33 aaron
shout out talking about that on the go
yes we will be talking about that later
in the show
i'm not the only one hooking it up aaron
fanduel is also hooking up new customers
for the conference finals
aaron we know you are the plug at
fanduel we know you are highly tapped in
tell the audience what's up so debuting
with the conference finals
new customers can get 30 to one odds on
any team to win their next playoff game
max bet is five dollars but at thirty to
one odds that's a chance
to win 150 so again if you are a new
customer
sign up now and take advantage of this
please i mean 30 to one i know all i
gotta say is
wow yeah those are those are good eyes
all i gotta say is wow
uh let's move on to our first segment
fanduel is also
running our favorite bet the sunset bet
the three by two for every game the rest
of this playoffs i am excited
but we asked you on twitter we asked you
on twitter where there will be two
three-pointers in the first
three minutes of tonight's atlanta
milwaukee game
there it is aaron you see it it's plus 1
30 tonight
plus 130 here are the results
you guys are riding with the 3x2 you
guys are riding with the 3x2 i love this
because
i love this you know aaron i'm all about
sunsets and vibes when it comes to three
by two but what i need you guys
what i need you guys to do is get in the
comments and tell me if the three
by two will hit tonight aaron what is
your take
i'm at the point where you just always
take the three by two you get immediate
action right from tip off plus for
yesterday it's at plus 130
great value i dug up a quick note as
well for the audience atlanta is hitting
37 percent of their threes this season
while the bucks
are hitting 39 of their threes we have
shooters on both sides
so give me the three by two for the mere
fact that i like to have fun
right from tip off plus great odds
who doesn't like to have fun and who
doesn't like good vibes aaron
all the sunsets well that's what we're
that's what we're about here
uh i'm in the comments right now because
it is hoodie time it is hoodie time i'm
giving away hoodies
for solid takes four solid takes will
the three by two cash my guy jason wade
13 says yes
shout out to you jason wade 13 you're
walking away with a hoodie shout out to
your vibes
jacob miller jacob miller has a raider
has a raider logo has his profile
picture but shout out to you jacob
miller
you're walking away with a hoodie shout
out to the the raiders as well jt
for mvp zero jt for mvp zero
is also rocking with the yes they're
[ __ ] aaron
we are all we are all riding with the
yes
riding with the yes as one big happy
family as one big happy family erin
let's move on to the next segment how
many points
will trae young score we asked you in
the app we asked you guys
in the app how many points would trae
young score tonight against
the bucks there it is that's the that's
the picture we asked you guys
uh you guys let us know get in the
comments tell me
how many points trae young is putting up
at the end of the game we'll dm
one person who gets the closest and hook
you up with a
jer zee of your choice aaron trey is
sitting at 28 and a half
do you like that number so trey young to
me is like that gnat you spotted him he
just doesn't go away we saw this when
the hawks
took three games from philly on the road
now looking back to the regular season
the bucks and hawks met three times
the bucks took two games trey young
played in just one of those three games
and it happened to be in a loss
he posted 15 points six turnovers and
went 0-4-3 from beyond the arc all
thanks
to drew holliday so trey is currently
averaging 29 points per game
in this playoff so far he's clutch but
tonight i have to take the under 28 and
a half given that i think holliday
is absolutely going to slow him down now
another interesting stat that i read
this morning greg
young is one for 10 in his career when
holiday has been the closest
defender on his shots so give me trey
young under 28 and a half points
aaron if anybody was digging up entry it
was me
it's nobody other than you aaron
dolan shout out to you for digging up
those interesting stats
uh let me get into the comments right
now and give away some hoodies
let me give away some hoodies how many
points will trae young score i'm in the
comments right now
looking for takes looking for takes i
got
not ronald acuna junior saying trey is
scoring 36 tonight aaron
rod not ronaldo junior i don't know
about him
i feel like he's always on that's right
not ronaldo jr
shout out to not ronald cunha jr uh i
also
see skate but it's skate with an eight
so it's engine skate
s-k-a-t-e he's going with 28
wow getting losing by the hook i mean
the unders winning by the hook
moving right along moving right along
richie 21 richie 21 says 26 points
shout out to everybody shut up everybody
i just mentioned you are walking away
with a hoodie uh i guess it's time for
me to me to me to
dig in here and this milwaukee bucks
team
they faced you know the nets the nets
and kd
james harden uh kyrie irving kyrie
irving early on in the series
and they were constantly i mean you know
it was low scoring it was
it was a low scoring affair this next
team used to they put up 140 130 with
ease during the regular season yeah so i
think that trend of defense is going to
continue in this one
i do think the bucks are gonna have the
clamps and then you just mentioned your
interesting stat
with drew holiday garden trey young yeah
shout out to you aaron
i am rocking with the under i'm rocking
with the under 28 and a half
i do see a lot of defense will be played
tonight and remember we're gonna
we're gonna hit one of you guys up after
the game and hook you guys
up with a jersey but i got more jerseys
to give away
right now so let's head over to the next
segment aaron i was looking at the
series odds for the hawks
and bucks and saw the hawks are actually
being offered at
plus two and a half games let's put the
odds up there it is right there
there it is plus two and a half games
that actually means that
they only have to win two games in the
series for this
bet to cash aaron isn't that crazy it's
crazy because you don't think they're
gonna be able to do that but then we saw
they played against the
knicks and my philadelphia 76ers
absolutely upsetting them
so sometimes it's hard to doubt this
team
right it is hard to doubt this team but
what i
need you guys not to doubt is get in the
comments
and tell me if you think the hawks are
going to win at least two games in the
series i'm going to give away hoodies
i'm going to give away a jersey
aaron this seems juicy to me
no i mean i definitely see why this is
enticing i don't see the series going
seven games so for me if you think
atlanta is going to win at least
two games go for it now the hawks were
relentless
in that series against the 76ers but if
you do think the bucks are going to win
4-1
or could sweep atlanta take bucks minus
two and a half
plus money to win this series right now
i lean more towards the buck
bucks excuse me but in all honesty i
just feel more confident
confident staying away from this market
at least until after game one
there is nothing wrong with staying away
there's nothing wrong with staying away
aaron let me get
into the comments let me see if they
stayed away or if they
rode with the hawks or milwaukee uh
i'm in the comments and i see i see uh
jeffy hofer zero zero jeffy hope for
hopefully i did not
butcher your name he says nah bucks four
to one nah the bucks has went in four to
one shout out to you jeffy
you are walking the hoodie
yeah take it to the yeah baller baller
20 21 says buxon six
bucks in six shout out to you baller
2021 you are walking away with the
hoodie
aaron it's time to give away a jersey
i'm in the comments i am in there that's
what yours needs to get
lots of jerseys to give away uh here we
go i see
i see hold on hold on i'm still looking
i'm still looking
i got em go blue and go blue is in the
comments once again
rich bartels rich bartel says
milwaukee n4 milwaukee and four shout
out to you rich bart tales
you are walking away with a jersey you
are walking away with a jersey shout out
to you
uh i like milwaukee here erin you talked
about your interesting stat
of drew holiday guarding trae young
i talked about the defense being applied
from this milwaukee team
and i don't see anything changing i
honestly don't see anything changing
i'll take i'm taking the bucks minus two
and a half i just they might they might
sweep aaron they honestly might sweep so
we'll see
i got one more jersey to give away so
let's keep moving let's keep moving
uh the clippers are two games down yep
to the suns
but they've come back from two games
deficit
twice already this year can they do it
again
with no kawhi let's look at the odds
for the clippers to win the series there
they are there they are 540. plus
yes aaron you see them they're sitting
that plus 540 get in the comments and
tell me if you think
it's worth a sprinkle i'm giving away
hoodies aaron what is your take
on this so can the clippers come back
possibly
but will they that's obviously the
ultimate question here game two is so
exciting last night the clippers had it
and they should have been able to win
that game but obviously they did not the
clippers really need to win
back-to-back games at home to give me
any type of faith in this team now i
know this price
plus 540 is enticing we saw this type of
number
when the bucks went down two games right
away against the nets now they're the
favorite
to win the title but to me the clippers
coming back all depends
on the health and availability of kauai
leonard he stayed in la to nurse and
rehab his knee
over the last two games we're still
waiting on his status for game three
while we now know
that chris paul does intend to come back
for game three it's a tough spot for
bettors when looking at this number it's
very juicy
plus the clippers are going to head home
for the two games it's
worth a look and a sprinkle of money but
ultimately i do think
the suns are going to be able to win the
series and the clippers won't bounce
back
aaron is rocking with the suns i am in
the
comments right now aaron giving away
hoodies uh
i see what a guy what a guy 24 has
a gift and it's of a sunset and he says
clippers doesn't have a chance
shout out to you what a guy 24 you are
walking away with the hoodie aaron i'm
giving away one more giving away one
more
do it i got parlay picker 48.
parlay picker 48 says hot take clippers
will win the next game but they cannot
come back for good
due to pandemic p wow
i don't know how i feel about that but
shout out to you parley picker 48
you were walking away with the hoodie
let me hop in here
in the first round they came back from
in the first round they came back from a
2-0 deficit in the second round they
came back from a 2-0 deficit
now they're down 2-0 so the clippers
have been here before
they've been here before they're at plus
5 40.
it's worth a little sprinkle it's worth
a little sprinkle in my opinion
they should have won last night they
should have won last night
we'll see they're taking it back to la
we'll see how they play
might get kawhi back but i'm i'm kind of
confident in the clippers being able to
come back from 2-0
just because i just saw it twice in this
playoffs you think they could do it a
third time now
i mean third time's the charm
you know so so we will see i got one
more jersey to give away
in the next segment we got two heavy
favorites
in the conference finals and we got two
heavy favorites in the conference finals
the suns the suns are in fact minus 770
to win
the west against the bucks no no to win
the west and the bucks
are minus 500 to win the east let's take
a look at the odds to win it all
let's take a odds to look at there it is
right there we see the clippers
we see the clippers at plus 1500 we see
atlanta
we see phoenix and we see milwaukee
uh get in the comments and tell me which
team is
is a better bet to win it all bucks sons
aaron what do you think so i think that
the bucks and the suns will meet in the
finals so looking at these numbers
between the favorites i am going to go
with the bucks even though there is
obviously
better value on some of the longer shots
like the clippers i don't think the
clippers are going to advance but
in your case greg you do so maybe you
want to put some money on them
at 15 to 1. another good example of this
like i mentioned already in the show
when the bucks were down two games at
the beginning of the series against the
nets
they moved to 16 to one to win it all
and now look at them plus 105.
would be a great payday for anybody who
was able to grab them at 16 to 1 to win
if the bucks do
indeed do that so for me i would take
the bucks that plus money between the
favorites
that i like at the moment
shout out to you aaron shout out to you
you are rocking with the bucks
let me get into these comments and see
what the fans are rocking
with i got ryan ray says son shout out
to you ryan ray you're walking away with
a hoodie i got
one horrible one harley senior one
harley senior
bucks will win it all she's rocking with
the buck shout out to you one harley
senior and i got
one more hoodie one more hoodie to give
away
jason wade jason wade 13 says
bucks beat the nets there's not a chance
anyone can beat them
rocking with the nets to win it all
aaron
it is time to give away our last
jersey our last jersey i am in the
comments
in the comments i got dylan
monter monteroses hopefully i did not
butcher that diamond monteross
bucks in six against the suns because of
their defense shout out to you brother
you were listening you were listening i
mentioned defense
you mentioned multiple times therefore
you were walking away
with the jersey of your choice aaron
i think that's it man i think that's it
thank you guys for tapping into the
group chat presented by fanduel remember
what you learned today the three by two
is a lot yup trey is not putting up over
28 and a half points
and the clippers just might
come back without kawhi we'll be back
next week
giving out more hoodies more jerseys and
more locks if
you want a hoodie we'll dm you
and you know what i'm going to give away
one more time just for fun
aaron a jersey why not i'm back into the
i'm back into the comments i'm back into
the comments giving away at jersey
as you're actually got a girl whispered
into my ear
producer westbrook hey give away another
jersey
here we go i got elliott elliott wire
0-8 elliott wire oh i got the suns
because of cp3's leadership
and da's improvement on defense that is
a hot take that is a hot take
hey alongside aaron dolan
i'm greg ivory and we're leaving the
group chat bye guys
[Music]
so
you